from The Daily Mail exclusive Hunter
gone wild unhinged videos show the
president's son dancing shirtless
slipping down a water slide naked and
entertaining hookers at debauched pool
party in 4 140 per night Malibu rental
wasn't the government paying for that
yeah to your service as well Secret
Service they were
hey man he's living his best life
so the one thing I'm gonna defend Hunter
here
one on one thing they show a clip of him
in jeans with no shirt on making eggs
and he's like dancing as he does it and
I'm like
this is pretty normal yeah Lydia said it
was like the least objectionable thing
is just like uh
[Music]
see this is the kind of thing that makes
them panic when you expose there's
another story which is probably more
important that Hunter Biden's being
accused of work working or being a
um under the control of foreign
influence like that's the real story and
so actually they're probably more happy
for us to talk about Hunter going wild
and you know I don't know just living
his best life with group sex because
that when they can try to make the story
that conservatives mad Hunter lives
salacious life yeah they can completely
distract from well he was doing a lot of
of negotiations and offering access to
his dad for a lot of money yeah they
want to make it a tabloid story when the
the truth is Joe Biden said I don't know
if people remember this Joe Biden said
you know I had no knowledge of Hunter's
business dealings at all and then all
you know the leaks come out of all the
email emails of of you know he's gonna
meet with uh with Biden's uh business
partner on a trip over to China and then
the uh and then the other uh emails of
Hunter Biden setting up the family
office in Georgetown where he he's going
to need keys for Joe Biden and his his
Chinese business partner and it's like
has anyone asked Joe Biden why he lied
about whether he had knowledge of Hunter
Biden's business dealings he obviously
did but instead of of talking about that
we're now redirected onto this tabloid
stuff it's fascinating yeah
yeah and he was wanking out on camera
okay
claiming that like he can't support uh
the child that he had with a with a
stripper that Joe Biden refuses to
acknowledge the grandchild that is wild
that's that's amazing I think the whole
story also goes down to the relationship
that Biden has with his family I think
there's a lot of contention there
especially with the latest kind of diary
that also has been uh cooperated by the
federal authorities that also have a lot
of serious questions I think uh at the
end of the day there was a lot more to
this father-son relationship that is
very Troublesome that I think is worth
investigating more as well because if
you truly look at Biden I mean there's
so many instances where you could say
holy cow this this this is leading down
a pathway of something very dangerous of
something very nefarious of something
really nasty and bad that I think we're
still only scratching the surface of and
as we're investigating every little
detail about Donald Trump's private life
I'm so glad you said that because it's
absolutely fascinating that we're
talking about a a court case in New York
on Donald Trump and the raid of
Mar-A-Lago meanwhile you know the
current president United States son
selling access to his office we have all
we know all this stuff to be facts now
and there's no investigation in Congress
right now on any of that stuff but I
know that Republicans have said and
they've promised if we retake the house
that they're going to subpoena people
and we're gonna start to have
investigations on this I really hope
that they do and I mean the greatest
irony to me is that like you hear case
after case that's in filed against Trump
all the allegations that the media was
told to go and report on all these
things that Donald Trump did in Russia
well actually the hunter Biden was doing
all all along while arranging deals with
the vice president of the United States
to capitalize on this and when they talk
about oh Donald Trump must be
compromised there's all this compliment
meanwhile the the president's son is
doing a lot of mad stuff while setting a
business this is it's it's a censorship
it's stuff like this that makes me want
to vote for Trump more than ever yeah I
I really do think DeSantis would be
better I really especially with the
Martha's Vineyard thing I mean that was
brilliant it was it was genius it was it
was a master stroke but uh but Donald
Trump just I understand why people so
many people were like he's gonna come in
and just kick the door in on the
establishment and uh knowing how much
they despise and fear Him
when they do stuff like this when they
lie cheat and steal when they censor and
scream like little whiny babies having a
temper tantrum I'm like all right fine
get Trump just bring Trump in geez you
know I was willing to give you a
DeSantis at the very least but then you
said he was worse all right then I'll
give you your worst fear no room for
compromise you know I tried that I was
like hey maybe you know maybe we'll
we'll find a good Democrat and then
you're no you know what just sending
Trump and then let Trump do whatever he
wants I didn't care at this point I
think you know if Trump does run again I
think the one issue he's going to run
into is if he centers his campaign
around 2020 and the personal politics oh
yeah grievance and that sort of thing I
just I don't think it's going to
resonate with Republicans the same way
as when he was coming down you know the
golden escalator and was saying I alone
can fix it because a lot of people
believed I alone can fix it but now he's
been president and he's going to have a
record that he accomplished or didn't
accomplish while he was president and
there's going to be other people on
stage age attacking that and of course
um I speaking on behalf of all women
everywhere they view DeSantis as dreamy
and attractive and they would vote for
him over or Donald Trump any day so uh
DeSantis is a real path to Victory
because he didn't get all those ladies
hot and bothered but I think I mean why
do Santa's just having a lot of success
right now is because he's he's fighting
on the issues that animate the
Republican base yeah right you saw
recent polling in Florida six months ago
Trump was above DeSantis and I see
desantises DeSantis is talking about
he's putting up dubs and Trump's talking
about else yeah it's as simple as that
that's right and there's a lot to
criticize on Donald Trump especially
with his record when he was in office
there's a lot of things you could point
to especially even as a conservative a
republican being like yeah that was not
a smart decision that was not a good
move I don't want to get into it here
because I'll be talking for a while uh
but but DeSantis also is being attacked
very severely the corporate media came
out and they all called him a kidnapper
today they all call them a human
trafficker when of course he did what
essentially the Biden Administration has
been doing from months shipping migrants
all across the United States but when he
does it for a political reason he's now
being labeled he's now being sued he's
going to be dragged into court just like
Donald Trump has just like Alex Jones
has and he's being sued by an activist
organization that of course receives
money from a George Soros fund that is
connected to the open Society Network
and of course he's going to have more
legal battles now and I think there's
this is something important to note here
because a lot of the major opponents
against the current establishment all of
them are pretty much in court right now
and I don't think that's a coincidence
well this is a bit of a hobby horse for
me is that the issue of left-wing dark
money where you have billionaires you
you have a a Swiss billionaire hand York
this right who funded uh uh these
various left-wing groups and this is an
overseas billionaire this is a foreign
National foreign National who's spending
hundreds of millions of dollars here in
the US he's given over 3 million Stacey
Abrams over 16 million to Joe Biden to
influence what he wants to happen so so
these groups are allowed to exist
outside of of of of normal politics in
the sense that they don't have to report
the Russians the Russians spend a
hundred thousand dollars on Facebook ads
and and the Hillary Clinton the
Democrats want to break the internet
because of that fact and this Swiss
billionaire can spend hundreds of
millions of dollars impacting our
elections and the media is like well you
know what it's for a good cause and it
goes and it goes to all these left-wing
groups that that there are various
things like a demand Justice who
basically wants to just pack the Supreme
Court so there is no matter what they
can do you know there's still one body
in this country that has to follow the
Constitution that's the Supreme Court
and that just enrages them to no end is
that wait we thought if we control the
media and and we control you know big
Tech and we control Hollywood that means
that like everyone had to listen to us
why is the Supreme Court not following
what we want so they now have this
left-wing group pushing to pack the
Supreme Court and you see like so many
groups uh whether it's uh uh these like
fake news left-wing agencies oh yeah who
try to decide what is truth what is
false it's all funded by the same like
uh open air Society all the left-wing
groups are all funded by these
billionaires Arabella advisors remember
that name the umbrella organization that
feeds cash down to all of these groups
in this fake News Network that the left
left wing has created through couriers
Newsroom and State's Newsroom and all of
these you know the Michigan Advance is
just this it's this Michigan you know
local media thing and actually it's
funded by George Soros and this entire
network and it pushes left-wing
propaganda the news feeds of Americans
every single day but you know the thing
that's interesting is like you look at
the left the the left uh Wing you know
dark money folks who are like financing
things like this DeSantis uh the the
lawsuit against DeSantis you know where
is the lawsuit for all the migrants who
died in the back of that boxcar in Texas
that sheriff didn't care about that at
all did he no no
you know the same in the same county
where apparently these migrants come
from and he's freaking out this this
Democrat elected Sheriff what about the
story was 53 I think right yeah yeah
they were just locked in and died 102
degrees and that wasn't a big story for
them these people are well it's it's not
you know it's not a big deal because it
didn't happen in Martha's Vineyard you
know I mean these the the coastal Elites
who run our media only care about places
like Martha's Vineyard they don't care
about the Border they don't care about
the reality that millions of Americans
have to live you know live under when
you have to absorb million now millions
of we're breaking records millions of
people coming in across the border you
know the schools are overwhelmed the
social services and they can't take care
of 50 migrants well that's the Beach
Community that's the thing yeah you have
the coastal Elites who are who they show
up to like their various book parties
and everything they have to let each
other know I'm a good person which means
I you know I support uh Sanctuary cities
and in this house we believe yeah put
the yards in Victoria cities because
they never have to live with the
consequences of their beliefs that they
wish to impose on the rest of us just
the same way that they they're willing
to take private jets and demand everyone
else eat worms you know like it's the
exact same situation where now they're
having to live with the consequences of
their beliefs that they want imposing
everyone else and like whoa didn't even
take two days before they they're like
the military needs to get these people
out of our vacation area right now
so I'm gonna give a shout out real quick
before we move on to the next segment
someone had a really good idea they said
that I should set up an email address
where people can email so that we can
compile evidence of Shadow Banning and
use that in any potential lawsuits so if
you as a viewer of timcast have
encountered any suspected Shadow Banning
or strange anomalies email shadowband
timcast.com that's Shadow
b-a-n-n-e-d at timcast.com with
screenshots and an explanation I
understand for a lot of people it may it
may some people make mistakes and how do
you how do you send a screenshot of not
getting a notification and then they can
always argue like well we don't always
have notifications for everything but
people are saying it's a new phenomenon
but some people are pointing out they
can't comment that the videos are being
listed as as children's videos so they
can't interact at all which is just
insane and not in like not the case on
our end so they're clearly strange
happenings and I suppose the argument is
if we could compile enough of this and
show a pattern occurring among our
viewers we we may be able to at least
convince a judge something discernible
is happening and we should have a review
as to what I I don't know I talked to a
lawyer but I suppose if we can show a
pattern of activity then YouTube would
have to do a review or we'd be able to
get Discovery on any Communications
about restricting our show do you have
multiple Wi-Fi's here with different IP
addresses
I'm not going to talk about it well I'm
just saying I mean the video evidence is
the best evidence in theory
theoretically you could like you know
post a video and this notification will
go out and on a separate screen have you
know set up somebody as a subscriber and
try to see if you can catch it that way
and that's one way to do it I mean well
I'll tell you this right now for the
past couple of weeks we've had this
phenomenon where when I launched the
live stream we create a special little
thumbnail like you got you know before
before the show uh I'll I'll I press
record and we have a staring contest
because we're basically lining up this
thumbnail for some reason and it's
thanks to Ian for for catching this the
thumb the the video for IRL is just a
gray box with with nothing in it and so
that is I believe intentional because
what happens is people will be scrolling
YouTube and they see a gray box because
the thumbnail is what attracts people
and they just scroll past it and so
you know why is this happening why did
all of a sudden randomly our thumbnails
just stop appearing to me on my end I
see the thumbnail I I pull up my account
I go over I see the thumbnail I wonder
if this is for people who are passive
like if you're a passive viewer if
you're not subscribed if you watch
regularly you're just seeing a gray box
that that I think is it has been a huge
detriment and I think it's intentional
well the power that these companies can
wield using algorithms and their
technology to get the outcome that they
want is is unbelievable I saw this uh
research paper that a gentleman did
where uh he went to China he purchased a
phone there he signed up for a tick tock
account and then he saw what kind of
videos is recommending and all the
videos over there were like the Triumph
of the Chinese people and like look at
all these like amazing things we're
building these massive Bridges
educational videos nationalistic videos
and then and then he came to back to the
US he purchases the same model phone the
same model phone signs up for a tick
tock account all he sees is teenagers
talking about like I have mental health
issues and like left-wing causes and
anything that can make you feel more
depressing and scared and debauchery and
twerking Bingo yeah thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there